joining us right now to talk about the
rest of the college football world as
well is Bruce Feldman si.com college
football analyst and sideline reporter
of TCU and Kansas State on fs1 coming up
this weekend here's Bruce Feldman back
on the show how are you Bruce I'm doing
ok so let's talk upsets is Oklahoma
State due for one again what do you
think here you've got I see young that's
already handed the belt 1 yeah I don't
think they are because Baylor a couple
of weeks ago put a real scare into the
Cowboys archrival Oklahoma they hit some
big plays down the field not granted a
lot of it was some some busted
assignment from the sooner secondary but
I think I think that Oklahoma State will
go into this with their eyes wide open I
expect them to jump all over them early
they're so explosive offensively I just
don't think right now Matt rule and
program has enough to keep up with them
well what about k-state paying it
forward back to TCU in the same way TCU
did to Oklahoma State what do you think
about that one yet it rich to me this is
this is a legit upset alert kind of feel
to it we had our crew had West Virginia
at TCU last week and TCU had their hands
full if it wasn't for their punter
pinning West Virginia down deep in there
inside their own six for different times
I think West Virginia probably wins that
game it was a really bad offensive pass
interference call that went against West
reduce David sills
to me you know they I give credit to to
Gary Patterson staff they made some
really good trick play calls two of them
that kind of got their offense at least
on track a little bit watch out for bill
Snyder's team so they're so well coached
we're gonna see a different quarterback
here this weekend from them Jesse Ertz
is hurt we're gonna see Alex Delton he's
a very dynamic young quarterback you
know and I expected to expect the
k-state team to rally with their with
their starting quarterback down and now
here comes Tom Herman's first crack at
the Red Rivers showdown let's talk about
Oklahoma coming off of that shocking
loss to Iowa State now taking on Texas
what a fascinating matchup this is
coming up this weekend Bruce your
thoughts yeah especially given the way
that UT played last week
Sam Ehlinger they're they're terrific
young freshman quarterback we saw him
just kind of grit out and we'll his way
through some tacklers and you know he's
when I talked to Tom Harmon in the
spring there were two things that that
really jumped out at me one he said that
Sam he thought reminds him a lot of JT
Barrett who obviously he had when he's
the office Cornero high o state in terms
of you know sturdy physical guy who can
give you enough in the run game he's not
gonna be a home run hitter and but he's
gonna hit you doubles and singled and
keep it moving and he's a real leader
has a presence to him and we're starting
to see that the other thing he said was
that this Texas receiving court led by
Colin Johnson is a six six 215 pound
sophomore is more talented and better
than the group that they won the
national title with in Columbus remember
last week and even against Baylor Mike
Stoops his defense had all kinds of
problems you know on defense I think
Texas can give them their hands full but
the question is going to be you know
Baker Mayfield with the loss
notwithstanding 15 touchdown zero picks
he's been carving up defenses I just
don't see him losing to Texas which is
basically the school he grew up around I
can't see him losing this last time out
and then Bruce Feldman Fox Sports si.com
Bruce Feldman here in the DirecTV 4k
college football report the other a big
upset of last weekend was Michigan State
going in the big house and turning
Michigan over five times in a wet
weather game where they prevailed and
they were a stouter team of which there
is no doubt what what about Michigan and
Indiana this week is there cause for
concern in your mind on that front there
is just because the Michigan offense has
been really sputtering we had both
Michigan and Michigan State the previous
two weeks and in different games and you
know I like the direction Michigan
State's back hit you know headed in
there's the really young no I did not
think they would be able to hold up for
four quarters against Michigan but right
now the way Michigan Michigan's
offensive line is not playing well what
we've come to expect to Jim Harbaugh
offense to look like
I mean defensively Don Browns got him
playing lights-out no question they are
yeah I think right now to me they're
going to win that
because Don Browns group is so good but
we got to see John Elkhorn like he looks
pretty good
went in our Purdue game on the road when
he had to step in now he looked really
good also when Purdue had its two best
players get thrown out of the game for
targeting penalties not kind of helped
open things up with the tight end and
everything but they gotta find a way to
protect him better and they also have to
find a way to really get the run game
cranked up the way we would expect a
Michigan run game to because that's
that's gonna be the best thing that can
help him out certainly since Penn
State's on the other side and you know
they got to go point four point with
that team to say the least before it
lets you go what is happening with USC
and the conversation that you hear in
Los Angeles about the play calling and
clay Hilton's play calling and how Sam
Darnell does even had to apologize for
some of the comments where that might be
perceived that he has a problem with the
play calling what is happening with the
Trojans who are taking on Utah at home
you know I think they're struggling with
the high height expectations and all the
hype that goes around the end USC when
people all board the bandwagon you know
you have to really three different guys
you were really heavily involved in the
play calling mix clay his brother Tyson
works with quarterback some team art he
was obviously a great quarterback
himself in college and now works for the
receivers and is really the OC there and
I think just about being on the same
page of what they want to do but the
reason why this is magnified is because
they are so inexperienced and kind of
patchwork offensive line that I think is
exposing a lot of things I mean you know
Sam darl I still think is a terrific
young player and they have a great
running back in Ronald Jones but a lot
of this stuff is is hard for them to
kind of get into any kind of offensive
identity because of the offensive line
is such a mess and I think that you
couple that with an inexperienced group
of receivers again the question I would
have you and I think it's a valid
question even you know somebody would
ask them to Arnold or somebody to ask
clay or T is what do you think the
identity of us sees offense is right now
I don't think anybody has a real it
doesn't seem like they have a real
handle on that at this point well and
then you just tell me if I'm wrong I
view this is there's no way this kids
going back to USC I mean
or or he's making some comments right
here to say if you want me to stay let's
listen to what I like and let's start
running stuff that makes me more
comfortable is there is that is that a
subtext that me is an NFL guy is reading
into something that's not there or or is
there any smoke to that Bruce I think my
feeling has always been that I expected
him to come back in 2018 he hasn't
played all that much football yeah he
didn't play a ton neither did your
Biscay I mean we could go on and on
about that yeah I just look at it some
of the pieces around him I USC should be
a lot better in 2018 around him
especially on the offensive line where I
think that's where it's missing the
receivers same thing it's just you know
he didn't even strike me as a guy who
was like I can't wait to get into the
NFL I think he liked and granted
everything was going rosy when they're
beating Penn State and you know long on
that roll but I think he likes being the
USC starting quarterback I think he
really was comfortable with it I don't
think there was a huge rush for him to
get into the NFL and I don't I don't
think those things have changed I think
what's important is right now they're
going through some rocky times my gut is
by November they will have God and
sorted out I don't think he's gonna rush
out the door I don't see this mushroom
into into an epidemic I really don't I
think you know say what you want about
clay Helton I don't I think clay
Helton's got a got a feel for what the
right thing to do is and how to sort
some of this out but right now I think
you know it has definitely been some
rocky moments and and I do think it'll
clear up just because of the people
involved will kind of see that you know
they got to get this on track and figure
out what's what's most important and
right now I think they're just kind of
lost away a little bit Bruce thanks to
the time appreciate it always we'll chat
soon my pleasure thank you guys it's
Bruce Feldman of Direct TV 4k college
football report the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy